willkommen an der Wall Street dem
Epizentrum der finanziellen macht in
Amerika vielleicht der geldhauptstadt
der Welt
die global ausgerichteten
Finanzunternehmen hier an der New Yorker
Börse haben außerordentlichen Einfluss
auf die Politik dieses Landes aber das
niemand hat sie gewählt und tatsächlich
versuchen diese Finanzfirmen die vom
Kongress erlassenen Vorschriften und
neuen Gesetze die sie regulieren wieder
rückgängig zu machen
die Leute an der Wall Street sind nur
einige von vielen nicht gewählten und
sehr mächtigen Kräften die im Schatten
hinter den Kulissen agieren sie sind die
medienkräfte die militärischen und
industriellen Kräfte sie sind die
gesellschaftlichen Kräfte
und die Kräfte die wir in dieser
Fernsehserie untersuchen werden die eine
Frage stellt die die meisten unserer
Medien nicht stellen
wer regiert Amerika
alle vier Jahre gehen die Amerikaner an
die Urnen um einen Präsidenten zu wählen
das ist ein Ritual das bis zur Gründung
der Nation im Jahr 1776 zurückreicht
alle vier Jahre beherrschen Politik und
Politiker unsere Fernsehbildschirme und
unsere Nachrichten und dominieren unsere
nationalen Diskurs
[Musik]
Präsident Barack Obama kandidiert für
die Wiederwahl mit mit Romy steht auf
der Seite der Ölriesen die sich gegen
höhere verbrauchsstandards und
erneuerbare Energien wenden er greift
die Republikaner an und wird von ihnen
angegriffen er sagte er würde die
Wirtschaft in drei Jahren umkrempeln
oder wird nur eine Amtszeit haben wir
sind hier im zusammen okay
die beiden Parteien mögen einen
politischen Krieg führen aber experten
bezeichnen Ihnen als ein Pferderennen
das buchstäblich durch Milliarden von
Dollar an Wahlkampfspenden angeheizt
wird
für die allgegenwärtige Werbung
Display und posies really at home
[Musik]
der Schwerpunkt liegt auf politischen
Persönlichkeiten nicht auf den Kräften
die sie repräsentieren eine große
Industrie von Kommentatoren und
Meinungsforschern wird dafür bezahlt und
zu sagen wer vorne liegt und wer hinten
der Schwerpunkt liegt immer auf den
Kandidaten nicht auf den Themen aber
jeder weiß dass die Kampagnen hinter den
Kulissen von professionellen Strategen
Medienexperten und politischen Beratern
geführt werden
die politische Werbung ist zynisch und
gewieft
fast jedes Wort steht in einem Drehbuch
Symbole sind Trumps Inhalt Slogans sind
Markt getestet um die Wahrnehmung zu
fördern und Vorurteile zu verstärken
Marketing ist die Mission verkaufen
nicht erzählen auf einer Ebene wird
dieses ganze Spektakel als Triumph der
Demokratie dargestellt als ob der
Kandidat der gewinnt das Land führen
wird aber im Amt zu sein bedeutet nicht
unbedingt an der Macht zu sein die
Amerikaner glauben dass sie über ihre
Zukunft bestimmen tun sie das wissen die
meisten oder wird ihnen jemals gesagt
wer Amerika regiert ich glaube dass
diese Leute man kann sie nicht wirklich
sehen das ist das was ich denke ja die
Leute die Amerika regieren die Leute
sind hinter dem Bildschirm sie sind
hinter dem Bildschirm unsichtbar
für die Allgemeinheit und glauben Sie
dass die Leute wirklich wissen was vor
sich geht
bis zu einem gewissen Grad ja und bis zu
einem gewissen Grad nein in welchem
Ausmaß ja in welchem Ausmaß nein etwa
wer regiert Amerika darauf gibt es keine
eindeutige Antwort der mit einem
Pulitzer Preis ausgezeichnete
amerikanische Historiker Eric former
sagt dass diese Frage viele weitere
Fragen über die Macht aufwirft die im
Verborgenen wirkt
wer regiert Amerika wissen sie es gibt
keine einzelne einfach zu definierende
Gruppe die Amerika regiert aber ich
denke nicht nur jetzt sondern seit ein
paar Generationen haben wir das was der
soziologische Mills in den 50er Jahren
eine Macht Elite nannte eine ineinander
greifen der Reihe von Verbindungen von
Menschen in der Wirtschaft in der
Politik im Militär die so ziemlich die
Parameter möglicher Veränderung
bestimmen
das ist nicht so dass sie Amerika auf
eine verschwörerische Art und Weise
regieren und natürlich gibt es gewählte
Beamte aber der Spielraum dieser Beamten
wird durch das eingeschränkt was man als
permanente Regierung bezeichnen könnte
Präsidenten kommen und gehen aber es
gibt eine Art permanente Einrichtung die
Präsident Eisenhower den militärisch
industriellen Komplex nannte aber jetzt
ist es eher ein militärisch finanzieller
komplex das liegt wirklich die Grenzen
fest
wir sind beim leftforum einer
Versammlung von Intellektuellen
Wissenschaftlern und Studenten die jedes
Jahr hier in New York stattfindet dieses
Jahr gibt es 1400 Sprecher sie sind sich
nicht in allem einig aber in einem schon
das Amerika nicht die Demokratie ist
dies zu sein vorgibt sie alle wollen
wissen wer regiert Amerika Professor
Stanley aronovic schreibt über die
Forschungen dieses Mannes seawright
Mills der vor einem halben Jahrhundert
über die Existenz einer macht Elite
schrieb die Aktivisten heute als das
eine Prozent bezeichnen die Leute die
alles steuern
sein Beitrag zum Verständnis des Wesens
der Macht in Amerika besteht in erster
Linie darin drei institutionelle
Ordnungen zu identifizieren die zusammen
die Macht Elite bilden eine Elite die im
Allgemeinen nicht auf das Volk auf
demokratische Freiheiten und
demokratische Verfahren eingeht
unter sagte diese drei Gruppen seien die
kapitalistischen Institutionen das
Militär und die dritte Gruppe sei die
oberste Schicht des politischen
Direktoriums wie er sie nannte und das
sind die nationalen Führer wie die
Exekutive der Regierung
nicht einmal der Kongress er sagte der
Kongress sei auf der mittleren Ebene der
macht er sei nicht wirklich an der
Entscheidung über Kriege die wichtigsten
wirtschaftspolitischen Maßnahmen und so
weiter beteiligt er ist zwar auf einer
gewissen Ebene beteiligt aber im Grunde
ist der machtlos und er sagte dies habe
den ganzen anscheinend einer
progressiven und repräsentativen
Regierung untergraben das mag der Grund
sein warum in jüngsten Umfragen nur
sieben bis neun Prozent der Amerikaner
in beiden Parteien glauben dass der
Kongress das sogenannte Volkshaus
repräsentativ und in der Lage ist die
Probleme des Landes zu lösen
wenn die Politiker in einer
polarisierten und parteipolitisch
geprägten Katze Situationen gefangen
sind wer übt dann die Macht aus um zu
entscheiden was die Prioritäten und
Politik des Landes sein sollten das
haben wir Jacky Fowler gefragt einen
Redakteur des politmagazins mental
das ist extrem kompliziert ich glaube es
gibt nicht die eine bestimmte Antwort
darauf vieles von dem was derzeit in
Amerika passiert wird von Geld und
Geldgebern angeführt vor allem in
Washington aber ich glaube es gibt da
auch eine brodelnde Bewegung von unten
nach oben gibt es eine herrschende
Klasse in Amerika oder ist das ein
überholtes Konzept
ich bin der festen Überzeugung dass es
eine Klasse gibt besonders in New York
City aber ich glaube nicht dass sie sich
in irgendeinem Raum verstecken und Stils
aushecken es ist eher strukturell es
gibt bestimmte Clubs in diese gehen
bestimmte Straßen in denen sie leben sie
interagieren mehr miteinander wir haben
diese Frage Aaron Kraul gestellt einer
30-jährigen Mutter aus der
Arbeiterklasse in einer Kleinstadt in
Wisconsin die neben ihrer Ausbildung
zwei Jobs hatte
wer Amerika regiert
was ist da ihre Wahrnehmung
Leute die das Geld haben um das zu tun
Leute die die Ressourcen haben um einen
Lobbyisten nach Washington zu schicken
niemand aus meiner Stadt könnte es sich
leisten einen Lobbyisten zu schicken und
zu sagen hey Harley Davidson droht damit
seine Fabriken nach China zu verlagern
wenn nicht alle Lohnkürzungen hinnehmen
und das könnte unsere Stadt buchstäblich
lahmlegen
wir können es uns nicht leisten uns zu
verteidigen
haben sie als amerikanische Bürgerin das
Gefühl dass Sie in unserem Land macht
haben haben Sie das Gefühl dass sie die
Möglichkeit haben ihren Traum zu
verwirklichen
ich habe das Gefühl dass es mir
entgleitet ich glaube nicht dass ich die
Möglichkeit habe
denn je näher ich dem kommen würde
mein Traum ist es das College zu beenden
und für mich selbst zu sorgen und für
meinen Sohn zu sorgen
aber selbst das ist jetzt
ich sehe dass viele Leute in meiner
Position nicht einmal in der Lage sind
so weit zu kommen wenn also die Bürger
die eigentlich das Sagen haben sollten
sich nicht zuständig fühlen wer dann wir
haben herausgefunden dass es im Großen
und Ganzen die reichsten Amerikaner sind
die über nicht gewählte Institutionen
das Sagen haben und ihre eigenen
Interessen durchsetzen
es mag eine Kabale geben die die Dinge
lenkt aber am Ende Verschmelzen der
Staat und das System meint der
kanadische Politologe Leopard
ich glaube nicht dass es eine externe
Kraft gibt die den amerikanischen Staat
kontrolliert der amerikanische Staat ist
durch und durch kapitalistisch er tut es
nicht weil die Wall Street zu viel
Einfluss hat er tut es weil er
strukturell mit der Wall Street verwoben
ist er tut es nicht weil der
militärische industrielle komplex zu
viel Einfluss hat der tut es weil der
militärisch industrielle Komplex in ihm
steckt vom Staat finanziert wird Teil
des Staates ist
sicher gibt es Leute die sich
verschwören die im Verborgenen agieren
aber der Kapitalismus ist keine
Verschwörung die Leute die den Reichtum
haben sind keine Verschwörung wir wissen
wer sie sind wir wissen wie Sie Geld
kassieren sie nehmen das aus unserer
Tasche und stecken es in ihren da gibt
es kein großes Geheimnis
Street noch andere Kräfte zu geben die
unsere politische und wirtschaftliche
Richtung bestimmen
allen voran die führenden Unternehmen
Amerikas der politische analyst Michael
Claire beschäftigt sich seit 20 Jahren
mit der politischen Ökonomie des Öls und
sagt dass die Öffentlichkeit aufgrund
mangelnder Berichterstattung im Dunkeln
Tat berichten die Medien darüber
die Medienberichten größtenteils nicht
darüber tatsächlich sind die Medien
größtenteils gleichgeschaltet wegen der
werbe-dollars die die Öl- und gaslobby
zur Verfügung stellen sie sind sehr
stark von den Werbeeinnahmen abhängig
also passen sie sehr darauf auf was sie
sagen wem gegenüber sind sie
rechenschaftspflichtig gibt es Gesetze
die ihr Handeln kontrollieren und
regulieren
es gibt Gesetze aber sie wurden
größtenteils von ihren Hobbyisten zu
ihren Gunsten geschrieben die Gesetze
sind zum größten Teil zu ihren Gunsten
nicht zugunsten der Meister Amerikaner
gibt es ein Thema bei dem man das
deutlich sehen kann wo die Interessen
der Ölindustrie oder der
Energieindustrie mit den Interessen der
Amerikaner in Konflikt stehen
nun ich würde als Beispiel anführen dass
die Ölindustrie auf Bohrungen in den
tiefen Gewässern des Golfs von Mexiko
und vor der Küste Alaskas gedrängt hat
und Sie erhalten alle möglichen
Steuervorteile für diese
Tiefseebohrungen während der
buschperiode konnten sie das ohne
jegliche Aufsicht tun deswegen auch die
die water Horizon Katastrophe
die meisten Amerikaner erleben die
Ölindustrie an zwei Stellen an der
Zapfsäule wo die Preise oft aufgrund von
Spekulationen und nicht aufgrund von
Angebot und Nachfrage steigen und auch
durch die Fernsehwerbung die dieses sehr
profitable Geschäft in den positivsten
Bildern darstellt ich bin immer noch
hier und BP ist es auch wir setzen uns
für das Ziel ein für alle die es lieben
und für alle die es ihr zu Hause nennen
das ist gut für die Energie die
Sicherheit und die Wirtschaft
das bringt uns zu einer anderen Gruppe
von Unternehmen den Medienunternehmen
Jeff Cohen war in den Medien tätig und
hat Bücher darüber geschrieben wie
Amerikaner über ihr Land und sein
Machtsystem denken eine System er sagt
das Medienunternehmen Propaganda für den
Krieg machen
wir sind genau dieselben Medien die
genau dieselben Experten zitieren die
unser Land und die Welt in einen Krieg
mit dem Irak getrieben haben und uns
wurde von diesen Medien gesagt oh es tut
uns so leid wir wussten nicht wissen Sie
wir haben einen Fehler gemacht das
nächste Mal werden wir wachsamer sein
aber hier sind wir das nächste mal 10
Jahre später und dieselben Medien werfen
Nebelkerzen über ein Waffenprogramm im
Iran das ist gar nicht gibt es gab auch
keine Massenvernichtungswaffen im Irak
wenn die Kriegstrommeln schlagen und ich
habe vor dem Irakkrieg in den Mainstream
Fernsehnachrichten dieses Landes
gearbeitet wenn die Kriegstrommeln
schlagen lassen sie dich keine
gegenteiligen Ansichten zeigen
wir haben versucht gegenteilige
Ansichten zu bringen die die Beweise die
Geheimdienstinformationen in Frage
stellen die einen Angriff auf den Irak
rechtfertigen würden aber wir wurden aus
der Sendung geworfen es ist ein Albtraum
ein Albtraum der sich wiederholt
gleichzeitig glauben die meisten Leute
die in den großen Medien arbeiten und
ich natürlich auch das nicht sie glauben
das nicht sie haben das Gefühl dass sie
die Freiheit haben über Themen zu
berichten und dass die Sender viel
vielfältiger sind in ihrer Sichtweise
als Außenseiter wie sie oder ich sagen
würden
ein Baby
nun um diese Fiktion zu widerlegen muss
man sich nur anschauen was nach der
Invasion im Irak passiert ist
diejenigen von uns die die Beweise für
die Bedrohung durch
Massenvernichtungswaffen in Frage
gestellt haben hatten völlig Recht und
die meisten von uns wurden aus den
Fernsehsendern rausgeschmissen die Leute
die sich geirrt haben sind aufgestiegen
die Vorstellung dass sich Vielfalt in
den Mainstream-Medien oder guter
Journalismus durchsetzen hat sich in den
letzten zehn Jahren nicht bewahrheitet
weil die Journalisten die Recht hatten
bestraft sanktioniert oder aus den
Medien geworfen worden und die
Journalisten die sich geirrt haben haben
heute mehr Macht um im Iran Nebelkerzen
zu werfen als sie hatten als sie dass
sie mehr Rake getan haben
diese Leute die Institutionen besitzen
sind sich ihrer Macht sehr bewusst nicht
nur als Individuen sondern als Teil
einer dominanten Klasse sagt der
unabhängige TV-Produzent Brian drawley
es wird hier viel über Demokraten und
Republikaner geredet die für die
Demokraten Stimmen für die Republikaner
Stimmen es wird viel geredet über die
Reichen gegen die 99%. aber es gibt eine
gewisse Amnesie was die Struktur unserer
Gesellschaft betrifft die zu einem
bestimmten Zeitpunkt in diesem Land
zumindest eine gewisse Aktualität hatte
in den 30ern und sogar den 60ern konnte
man über die Arbeiterklasse reden heute
spricht niemand mehr darüber es gibt nur
noch die Mittelschicht und das eine
Prozent und dann gibt es vielleicht noch
ein paar arme schwarze und Latinos oder
so ich glaube dieses Wort wurde aus dem
Vokabular der Menschen in den USA
gestrichen auch aus dem Vokabular der
Linken nun ist das nicht die gesamte
Linke aber
selbst die Leute die das Wort Klasse
benutzen scheine nicht in der Lage zu
sein ist so zu formulieren dass es den
Menschen wirklich etwas bedeutet
[Musik]
es geht nicht um eine Verschwörung
sondern um ein komplexes System dass ich
im Laufe der Jahre entwickelt hat ein
System in dem es Schichten gibt und das
mit Wahlkampf Spenden und Lobbyarbeit
dafür sorgt dass die Politiker den
Wünschen der Unternehmen nachkommen
das sind also die Bausteine der Analyse
die wir für diese Serie erforschen
werden
das Argument ist einfach aber für viele
Amerikaner schwer zu verstehen weil
viele von uns an die Mythen glauben
wollen die wir in der Schule gelernt
haben und die uns das Gefühl geben
anderen Ländern und anderen Völkern
überlegen zu sein das hat man als
amerikanischen akzeptionalismus
bezeichnet viele Amerikaner glauben dass
Gott dieses Land als das großartigste
Land der Welt geschaffen hat und das sei
jetzt was es so besonders mache wir
müssen davon ausgehen dass die
Vereinigten Staaten auf dieser Grundlage
gegründet wurden proxen dann war orthes
ist eine prominente Vertreterin der
Ureinwohner Amerikas der ersten
Amerikaner
sie waren diejenigen die eliminiert
werden sollten weil man ihr Land wollte
nicht einmal ihre Arbeitskraft wie in
Lateinamerika
dort wurden die Ureinwohner versklavt
und zu Bauern gemacht
aber in Nordamerika auch in Neuseeland
und Australien wollten die Briten sie
effektiv ausrotten und sich ihr Land
nehmen
es ist nicht nur so dass sie nicht
einbezogen wurden sie sollten eliminiert
werden
und so führen Fragen über die Hüter der
wirklichen macht und wer Amerika regiert
zurück zu Debatten darüber wie man die
Macht neu gestalten kann wie man ihre
Verteilung in Frage stellt und sie
transparenter und
rechenschaftspflichtiger macht
das sind die Fragen die die occupie Wall
streetbewegung aufwirft indem sie die
institutionelle macht in Frage stellt
und versucht die Basisdemokratie
wiederzubeleben
David erklärt die Ursprünge von occupie
aufeinander alles bewegte sich in diese
Richtung ich habe mich in der Welt
umgesehen da waren die Proteste in
Ägypten es ging weiter zum Arabischen
Frühling Tunesien und ganz Europa kam
zurück und es war nur eine Frage der
Zeit bis es die Vereinigten Staaten
trifft
wenn man sich die Bewegung weltweit
anschaut sie wurden einfach etwas was
man tun muss es war eine natürliche
Entwicklung dass sie hier ankommt ich
glaube sie ist jetzt hier weil
obwohl der Reichtum so konzentriert ist
haben die Menschen ein Mediensystem in
dem sie so propagiert werden dass sie
sich isoliert fühlen
aber occupie zeigt dass die Menschen
nicht alleine leiden sie erzeugen ein
Bewusstsein und haben den nationalen
Diskurs verändert
die Bewegung hat es mit mächtigen
Kräften zu tun die über große Budgets
verfügen und von der Polizei und dem
politischen Establishment unterstützt
werden während diese Aktivisten an
vorderster Front für ein vom Volk
regiertes Amerika kämpfen teilen viele
seiner Bewohner die gleiche Hoffnung
ist der Begriff der Klasse wichtig in
diesem Land das ist da eine Oberschicht
gibt eine Arbeit Klasse
oh ja absolut
ich bin Kellnerin in einem sehr netten
Restaurant und mir sehr bewusst was
meine Rolle ist und wer ich bin
das merkt man einfach an den Gesprächen
die ich mit den Leuten führe
vor kurzem habe ich mit einem
Geschäftsführer eines ziemlich großen
Unternehmens in unserer Stadt gesprochen
und als ich erwähnte dass ich auf eine
öffentliche Schule gehe
bekam ich eine Art Augenrollen und oh ja
meine Steuergelder bezahlen das müssen
sie
haben Sie das Gefühl dass es
Ressentiments gegen arbeitende Menschen
gibt so nach dem Motto die haben das
Bisschen was sie bekommen nicht verdient
auf jeden Fall
vor allem wenn man die jüngsten Angriffe
auf Angestellte des öffentlichen Sektors
sieht zum Beispiel auf Lehrer die Leute
sagen sie verdienen diese Leistungen
nicht wir alle bekommen diese Leistungen
nicht also verdienen Sie sie auch nicht
warum ist diese Diskussion nicht er wir
sollten alle daran arbeiten diese
Leistungen für alle zu bekommen anstatt
sie den wenigen wegzunehmen die sie
haben
wenn ich sie reden höre wird mir klar
dass es hier um ein größeres Bild geht
die meisten Menschen erstmal verstehen
sollten
dass wir in einem Land leben in dem
vielen Menschen ihre Träume entgleiten
sie fühlen sich nicht besonders mächtig
sie haben nicht das Gefühl dass sie
etwas tun können
etwas bewirken können
ich glaube der Traum verschiebt sich zu
hoffentlich wache ich morgen auf und
kann meine Miete bezahlen und ein Dach
über dem Kopf haben oder es ist so ich
werde morgen an der Verwirklichung
meines Traums arbeiten
aber heute muss ich zum Unterricht gehen
ich muss meinen Job erledigen ich muss
zur Arbeit gehen und ich muss versuchen
ein paar Stunden Schlaf dazwischen zu
quatschen
sie sind hier auf dieser Konferenz mit
all diesen brillanten Theoretikern und
Analytikern und Professoren und Experten
und Führungskräften
was halten Sie von dieser Idee dass
Menschen zusammenkommen müssen um etwas
zu verändern
ich finde das ist wunderbar ich fühle
mich so geehrt dass ich hier mit solchen
Leuten zusammen sein kann
denn ich möchte lernen
jemand hat zu mir gesagt warum gehen sie
nicht von dort weg wo sie sind aber ich
glaube nicht dass das die Antwort ist
ich glaube es ist meine Aufgabe als
jemand der sich für diese Dinge
interessiert von diesen Leuten zu lernen
von diesen brillanten Köpfen zu lernen
und so kann ich das zu den Leuten
zurückbringen und ihnen zeigen und
erklären wo wir ja nicht jeden Tag
Zugang zu solchen Dingen haben
und so kann ich versuchen Sie ein
bisschen aufzuklären
Aaron drückt die Hoffnungen vieler
gewöhnlicher Amerikaner aus die die
Natur der Macht umgestalten wollen
sodass die 99 Prozent nicht nur das eine
Prozent regieren können aber wir sehen
auch dass sie nicht glaubt diesen Kampf
gewinnen zu können vielleicht ist das
der Grund warum sie wissen will wer
Amerika regiert
diese Frage wurde im Laufe der
amerikanischen Geschichte immer wieder
diskutiert
ursprünglich wurde sie in den 1770er
Jahren in der amerikanischen Revolution
aufgeworfen und bis zu einem gewissen
Grad beantwortet als die Amerikaner für
die Unabhängigkeit von der britischen
Krone kämpften damit zumindest einige
von ihnen sich selbst regieren konnten
wir sind an der Columbia University mit
dr Eric Forner einem Historiker und
Schriftsteller der hier schon seit
langem lehrt
was heute ungewöhnlich ist sind zwei
Dinge erstens das Ausmaß der
Ungleichheit noch nie zuvor hatte das
oberste Prozent so viel des nationalen
Einkommens und Vermögens in den eigenen
Händen so dass die Kluft größer ist als
je zuvor und zweitens Occupy Wall Street
ist nicht eine Bewegung von Bauern von
Arbeitern sie hat nicht die gleiche
Basis die Leute müssen die Geschichte
lernen dass es Teil unserer Aufgabe zu
wissen dass es dieses Thema schon lange
gibt es war nichts unamerikanisches
daran die Frage der wirtschaftlichen
blutokratie der Ungleichheit aufzuwerfen
das ist so amerikanisch wie Apfelkuchen
ich glaube dass die Occupy Wall Street
Leute legitime Erben einer langen und
ehrwürdigen Traditionen in diesem Land
sind
heute setzen die Aktivisten von occupie
Wall Street den Kampf für Unabhängigkeit
und Gerechtigkeit fort gegen die
Beherrschung durch eine kleine Elite im
Namen der Mehrheit der 99% Amerikas
das geniale an der Occupy Wall Street
Bewegung ist die Gegenüberstellung von
einem Prozent und
99%. was wir im Grunde haben ist eine
undemokratische Machtstruktur die sich
über politische wirtschaftliche soziale
und kulturelle Grenzen hinweg erstreckt
welchen Einfluss hat Occupy Wallstreet
darauf dass Fragen über die Natur der
Macht in Amerika aufgeworfen werden
das haben wir den Soziologen Stanley
aronovitz gefragt
sie haben die Wahrnehmung beeinflusst
die Diskussion verändert die Frage ist
ob Sie in der Lage sein werden die
Politik zu verändern mein Argument wäre
dass man sich nicht darum sorgen sollte
die Politik kurzfristig zu verändern der
einzige Weg die Politik langfristig zu
ändern ist eine noch größere Bewegung zu
schaffen und um diese größere Bewegung
zu schaffen müssen Sie die Frage stellen
was für ein Leben wollen wir führen was
ist ein gutes Leben was ist die Vision
wie wir leben wollen
den Ausdruck 99 Prozent ein Prozent
geprägt und war ein früher Organisator
von occupie er erklärt warum die Frage
wer Amerika regiert nach wie vor so
dringend ist
es gibt große Banken und konzentrierten
Reichtum der den politischen Prozess
manipuliert wenn man das untersucht
sehen wir ein Land in dem
Millionärshaushalte 46 Billionen Dollar
Reichtum haben das ist einfach unfassbar
in der letzten Generation ist der
gesamte Reichtum an die Spitze gegangen
es ist ein Zehntel von einem Prozent
nicht ein Prozent und wenn man es noch
weiter herunterbricht gibt es 400 Leute
die so viel Reichtum haben wie 155
Millionen Amerikaner also haben 400
Leute so viel Reichtum wie die Hälfte
der Bevölkerung
der keimende
als eine neue amerikanische Revolution
sehen ist nicht wirklich neu er ist tief
verwurzelt in der nicht bewältigen
Geschichte des Konflikts in den USA
zwischen denen die die Ressourcen
besitzen und denen die wirtschaftliche
Gleichheit fordern
die Frage ist wer regiert Amerika das
ist eine komische Frage weil man dann
Übermacht spricht das erste was man
verstehen muss ist dass Amerika ein
Geschäftsunternehmen ist gestohlenes
Land gestohlenes Eigentum Kapitalismus
es geht nur darum Geld zu machen
viele Revolutionen beginnen an der
Spitze die Leute die den Kampf gegen
Großbritannien begannen waren Kaufleute
in Boston und New York
Plantagenbesitzer in Virginia die
meisten Gründer in Virginia waren
Sklavenbesitzer aber als der Kampf
intensiver wurde mussten sie die
Unterstützung der einfachen Leute
gewinnen und wenn man das tut bricht man
das politische System auf und öffnet die
Tür für sehr unterschiedliche Arten von
Forderungen Sklaven fangen an ihre
eigene Freiheit zu fordern Frauen und
Ureinwohner fordern mehr
Gleichberechtigung was als am Anfang
passiert wenn eine privilegierte Klasse
den Widerstand beginnt sagt nicht
unbedingt etwas darüber aus wie der
ganze Prozess verlaufen wird
dieser Konflikt zwischen dem einen
Prozent oder eher 0,00 ein Prozent und
den 99% hat hier seinen Widerhall
gefunden in der Heimat von Amerikas
anticolonialem Aufstand in den
Seitengassen von Boston für heute der
Freedom Trail an ein Massaker durch die
Briten und den Kampf für die Freiheit
erinnert dorthin werden wir sie nun
führen
war die amerikanische Revolution
wirklich eine Revolution
die Briten hielten es für eine
Revolution keine Frage es war keine
soziale Umwälzung wie die Französische
Revolution aber sie stürzte ein ganzes
Regierungssystem sie ersetzte die
herrschende Klasse durch eine andere und
darum geht es ja bei einer Revolution
sie warf diese Fragen der Gleichheit in
der Gesellschaft auf nicht nur die
Gleichheit im Sinne von einem Prozent
und 99% sondern die Rolle des Sklaverei
im amerikanischen Leben der Status der
Frauen sie löste eine Art Kampf um
Gleichheit unter allen möglichen Gruppen
aus der noch lange nach der Revolution
weiterging
Listen
of the midnight right of Paul Revier das
ist eines der berühmtesten Gedichte der
amerikanischen Revolution und hier sind
wir vor der Statue von Paul Revier dem
Mann der ganz Massachusetts vor den
britischen Truppen warente die in ihre
Dörfer kamen wir sind auf dem Frieden
Trail in Boston wo waren die
amerikanische Revolution erinnert wird
was für eine Revolution war das was
geschah hier in Boston in den 1700er
Jahren was haben wir seitdem gelernt
Tausende von Touristen und Studenten
besuchen diese revolutionsdenkmäler
jeden Tag aber die meisten haben nur
eine verschwommene Vorstellung davon was
wirklich passiert ist und neigen dazu
die Mythen zu wiederholen diese in der
Schule lernen
hier war Paul Revier er war einer der
großen revolutionshelden
ihr seid also hier um die Statue von
Paul Revier zu sehen
darf ich euch was fragen wir machen hier
eine kleine Fernsehsendung wer war Paul
Revier wisst ihr das ein Gründervater er
hat den mitternachtsrip gemacht um vor
den Briten zu warnen
wusstet er dass er ein sehr reicher
Geschäftsmann war ein Silberschmied hier
in Boston und dass er in die
Kontinentalarmee wollte und sie ihn
nicht genommen haben das wussten wir
nicht wusstet ihr dass es in Boston
diese kaufmannsschicht gab ihr wisst
schon Wirtschaftsführer die ein Prozent
die das Sagen hatten und dass das Volk
nicht so sehr involviert war denn damals
gab es Sklaven es gab
Vertragsbedienstete es gab eine Menge
Leute die kein Mitspracherecht hatten
bei dem was vor sich ging habt ihr das
gewusst
nein keine Ahnung ich wusste nicht über
Paul Revier
ich sollte das wohl im
Geschichtsunterricht lernen mein Bruder
will hier unterrichtet seit vielen
Jahren Geschichte für Schüler in
Massachusetts und hat die verschiedenen
Debatten über unsere Geschichte verfolgt
was war das für eine Revolution war sein
Volksaufstand oder wurde sie von den
Eliten hier in Boston angeführt
nun beides trifft zu es gab
volkstümliche Elemente gewöhnliche
Menschen waren gegen die Briten
gewöhnliche Menschen beteiligten sich an
Aufständen und bei kurz aber es gab
damals auch dieses eine Prozent die
Anführer haben die Revolution nicht nur
angeführt sondern auch kanalisiert sie
waren nicht zimperlich wenn es darum
ging Worte wie Freiheit zu benutzen um
die Menschen abzulenken und von ihrer
eigenen Unzufriedenheit in den Kolonien
abzulenken und von ihren eigenen
Interessen die Geschäftsleute in Boston
wollten keine weiteren Steuern auf ihre
Produkte sie wollten mit den britischen
wahren konkurrieren sie während der
Meinung dass sie nicht besteuert werden
sollten und daraus entstand dann eine
erste Tea-Party hier in Boston
und es gab Kaufleute wie John Hancock
der warenschmuggelte und du hast recht
sie wollten keine britischen Steuern
zahlen es gab auch noch andere Faktoren
die hinter der Revolution standen aber
als 1787 im Verfassungskonvent
abgestimmt wurde waren die Leute die
eingeladen wurden die Großgrundbesitzer
die Sklavenbesitzer die Handelsklasse
keine Frauen keine Indianer keine
schwarzen keine Arbeiter
tatsächlich gab es Sklaven die durch die
Revolution inspiriert wurden für ihre
Freiheit zu kämpfen
die Idee der Revolution und die Idee der
Demokratie waren radikal inspirieren
revolutionär auf eine Art und Weise die
den Anführern vielleicht unangenehm war
da einige von ihnen selbst Sklaven
besaßen sie wollten nicht dass durch das
verbreitet wie überall in der Welt
America wer hat also damals Amerika auf
einer Art und Weise regiert wie es ihre
Enkelkinder heute tun
und manchmal auch direkt danach kommen
dieser Leute also ich glaube es gab ein
gewisses Maß an klassenmobilität
Schuldknechtschaft die durch das Chaos
der Revolution zerfiel aber ich glaube
nicht dass die Leute die die Revolution
anführten wirklich eine soziale
Revolution beabsichtigten das war
wirklich nicht das woran sie dachten
nach der Revolution versuchten Leute wie
Daniel Chase in westmassachusetts ein
Farmer ein Hauptmann in der Revolution
eine weitere Rebellion gegen diejenigen
zu organisieren die er als Ersatz für
seine britischen Herren ansah dieses Mal
waren es die Kolonialherren
[Musik]
hier sind wir also
225 Jahre nach dem chase-aufstand der
den Westen von Massachusetts
erschütterte und eine Herausforderung
für das eine Prozent jener Zeit
darstellt es gibt eine Gedenkstätte für
Daniel Chase und die Männer die mit ihm
kämpften
und was interessant ist hier sind
amerikanische Flaggen an seinem
Grabstein als Zeichen der Unterstützung
für die Werte und Ziele für die
erkämpfte
[Musik]
mein Name ist
Dave rodstein sie befinden sich in der
stage-coach terren in westmassachusetts
der Stadt chefield und dieses Gemälde
zeigt den Militär Daniel Chase Daniel
Chase Fehler war sie kamen von der
Revolution zurück und fanden ihre Farmen
zwangsversteigert und viele im Gefängnis
wegen der gleichen Schuldenkrise wie wir
sie heute erleben es gibt viele
Ähnlichkeiten aber im Wesentlichen war
eines der Versprechen der Revolution die
Auslandsschulden zu erlassen und dann
kamen die Farmer nach Hause und sahen
dass die Schulden noch größer waren und
die Banken noch strenger
heute ist Rebellion größtenteils
vergessen aber sie lebt auf Youtube
weiter mit Liedern und dramatischen
Darstellungen
und den Pfeifen und trommelspielern
befohlen eine Melodie anzustimmen die
Männer beginnen im Gleichschritt zu
marschieren die Ironie sagte Historiker
eric fauner ist das Chase nur ein
Frontmann für eine Massenbewegung war
tatsächlich waren es die gegner die von
Chase Rebellion Sprachen um eine Art
Feindbild zu erschaffen dass sie
angreifen konnten vergessen wir mal
Chase als Person und denken an die
Massenbewegung die Bauern die einfachen
Arbeiter die auf die Straße gingen die
Gerichte lahm legten und sagten moment
mal wir hatten eine Revolution wir haben
eine Regierung eingesetzt die das Volk
in Massachusetts vertreten soll und
jetzt sind es die Banker und
Grundbesitzer und Kaufleute die von
einem profitieren
es war die erste Wall Street Bewegung
sie haben bei der Regierung in Boston
eine Petition eingereicht und die
Regierung hat sie ignoriert und sie
hatten immer noch ihre Waffen sie sind
zu den Gerechten gegangen und haben
streitposten aufgestellt um zu
verhindern dass die Gerichte Tagen was
bis zu einem gewissen Grad gelungen ist
bis private Milizen gebildet worden und
das Ganze zu unterdrücken die letzte
Schlacht wurde in scheffelt geschlagen
sie wurde von Brigadier Ashley angeführt
das erschlägerhaus steht immer noch hier
die Eltern von Köln und Ashley gehört zu
den Helden der Revolution es ist also
dieselbe Familie die die Unabhängigkeit
aufbaute aber dann versuchte sie zu
unterdrücken
wenn viele weiße Amerikaner von den
Errungenschaften der Revolution
enttäuscht waren was ist dann mit den
schwarzen und den Ureinwohnern
1730 als Sheffield eingemeindet wurde
gab es 30 schwarze Familien in chefield
die Hälfte war versklavt die andere
Hälfte frei aber die berühmte Geschichte
spielt wieder im Ashley Haus eine der
Bediensteten Elizabeth Freeman genannt
mom Bett hörte am Esstisch ein Gespräch
über die Unabhängigkeitserklärung von
Massachusetts da kam mir der Gedanke
dass sie es versuchen könnte sie klagte
vor dem Gericht von great Barrington und
gewann ihre Freiheit da war also ein
Gericht das einerseits Freiheit gewährte
und sie andererseits unterdrückte Jahre
später wurde eine kleine schwarze
Gemeinde in der Gegend die Daniel scheiß
berühmt gemacht hatte zur Heimat eines
jungen Mannes der zu einem Anführer im
Kampf für die Bürgerrechte wurde er
verbannt die Sorge um die Gleichheit der
Rassen mit der Forderung nach
wirtschaftlicher Gerechtigkeit
im Zentrum seiner Heimatstadt great
Barrington
politischen und intellektuellen Beitrag
feiert mit Zitaten von Barack Obama und
Martin Luther King dr Double You ibi du
Boys
the boys war einer der Titanen des 20
Jahrhunderts also er ist im 19
Jahrhundert geboren du Boys hat die
Themen vorgebracht die uns immer noch
beschäftigen die Rassenfrage in Amerika
1903 sagte er das Problem des 20
Jahrhunderts sei das Problem der
Colorline es ist immer noch ein Problem
in der ganzen Welt du Boys hat über
wirtschaftliche Gleichheit gesprochen
und darüber wie man sie erreichen kann
er ist ein brillanter Schriftsteller und
Denker und vieles von dem Wasser gesagt
hat ist immer noch relevant wenn man
über die amerikanische Gesellschaft
nachdenkt
was ist mit den amerikanischen
Ureinwohnern
sie sollten eliminiert werden weil man
ihr Land wollte nicht ihre Arbeitskraft
ist Teil der amerikanischen Ureinwohner
Bewegung und sagt dass die Menschen die
wir Indianer nennen ausgerottet wurden
wir haben sie zu amerikanischen
Revolution befragt
es war keine Revolution es war ein Krieg
für Unabhängigkeit von der Übermacht
aber es war keine antikoloniale
Revolution wie die bolivarische
Revolution in Südamerika oder die
hyazianische Revolution
es gibt also viele verschiedene
Erzählungen über die Ursprünge der
Vereinigten Staaten
die Vereinigten Staaten wurden als
siedlerstaat gegründet als Kolonialstaat
sie wurden zu einer imperialistischen
macht und die Demokratie war immer eine
Oligarchie
eine kapitalistische Demokratie mit
einer Rhetorik des Populismus die stark
auf Rasse basiert
das heißt wenn du nicht schwarz bist
wenn du kein Sklave bist bist du nicht
in die Gegend wenn du weißt bist und ein
Siedler kannst du ein König sein kannst
Land besitzen und Großgrundbesitzer sein
all diese Bauern die als Siedler kamen
hatten den Traum der Boss zu sein
und so ist es eine sehr perfide Art von
Demokratie weil es eine Illusion ist
[Musik]
Illusion oder nicht das ist ein Thema
das untersucht werden muss wenn wir
verstehen wollen wer Amerika regiert wo
die Ursprünge des einen Prozent sind und
dann müssen wir darüber Lehren das ist
also alles ein Teil der Geschichte den
die meisten Amerikaner wahrscheinlich
nicht kennen hast du als du hier
unterrichtet hast festgestellt dass
viele der Schüler nicht viel über ihre
eigene Geschichte wissen
ich habe viele Schüler unterrichtet in
Städten die beim Gefecht von conquert
dabei waren die noch nie an dem Ort
waren an dem wir jetzt stehen es stimmt
dass viele Kinder nicht mit dieser
Geschichte vertraut sind abgesehen von
den lokalen Schlachtfeldern und so
die andere Sache über den
Revolutionskrieg die für heute relevant
ist weil wir in einer globalisierten
Welt leben ist dass die Revolution hier
in Boston begann
aber bald waren die Briten involviert
die Holländer die Franzosen
es wurde ein Krieg vieler Länder die
alle auf amerikanischem Boden kämpften
und die französische Intervention war
sehr entscheidend für unseren Erfolg es
war nicht allein durch die Kraft und den
Mut unserer Waffen es waren noch andere
Leute beteiligt aber ich glaube die Idee
selbst hat eine revolutionäre Rolle in
der Geschichte gespielt aber die Idee
selbst hat keine tiefgreifende soziale
Revolution in den USA ausgelöst bis
heute sind die Menschen durch Worte wie
Freiheit und Gerechtigkeit genauso
abgelenkt wie damals
ironischerweise war die ursprüngliche
Tea-Party die die moderne Rechte
teeparty-bewegung inspiriert hat
eigentlich ein Protest gegen eine
frühere Form des Unternehmens
Imperialismus
warum ging es um Tee und nicht um Mais
oder Whiskey oder sowas es ging darum
dass die east in ja company in China
bankrott gegangen war und die britische
Krone ihr aus der Patsche geholfen hat
damit sie ihr Vermögen nicht verliert
aber dann hat sich die Krone umgesehen
und gedacht was hat die Firma dass wir
verkaufen können und das was sie hatten
war Tee also beschlossen sie den Tee zu
vermarkten und der Tee wurde zum
Steuerproblem das ganze war ein großer
finanzieller Misserfolg es war global
die Auswirkungen schwappten über den
Pazifik schwappten über den Atlantik und
da war die bostonie
im Laufe unserer Geschichte gab es immer
wieder Verschwörungstheorien über all
das heute scheinen zum Beispiel sowohl
die rechte als auch die Linke die
US-Notenbank als eine Art Verschwörung
zu sehen die 1913 ausgeheckt wurde ohne
ein ordentliches Verfahren und die
praktisch das Sagen hat
ja wissen sie verschwörungsdenken ist
tief in unserer politischen Kultur
verankert mein Doktorvater mein Mentor
Richard Hofstetter schrieb in den 60er
Jahren ein berühmtes Buch und der
paranoid Style in American politics in
dem er verschiedene Arten von
verschwörungsdenken nachzeichnete ob es
nun die Katholiken waren die vor dem
Bürgerkrieg versucht in Amerika zu
untergraben oder andere Gruppen zu
verschiedenen Zeiten im Migranten andere
die versuchten die amerikanische Kultur
zu zerstören oder die Trilaterale
Kommission erinnern sie sich an sie in
den 70er Jahren sie regierte angeblich
die ganze Welt jetzt die Notenbank wenn
wir sie nur abschaffen würden würde
alles so Utopie der Vergangenheit
zurückkehren
in der gesamten US-Geschichte gibt es
verschiedene Rechte Bewegungen die
Sündenböcke in der Gesellschaft suchen
und das sind meist Leute die schon auf
die eine oder andere Weise
marginalisiert sind dann gibt es einen
Moment in dem es für die Macht Elite sei
es die Regierung oder Unternehmen
nützlich wird diese Bewegungen zu
ermutigen also bekommt man eine Teeparty
oder eine milzbewegung wie in den 90er
Jahren oder man bekommt den Ku-Klux-Klan
in den 1800er Jahren dabei geht es darum
wütende meist weiße Menschen zu nehmen
die etwas privilegiert sind und sie
davon zu überzeugen dass sie dabei sind
auf der sozialen und wirtschaftlichen
Leiter nach unten zu feiern
mit Verschwörungstheorien ist dass
keiner vollständig bestimmen kann was
passiert sogar Leute mit großer Macht
bringen Dinge in Gang und dann verlieren
sie irgendwann die Kontrolle darüber die
Dinge passieren auf einer Art die
unvorhersehbar ist
wenn man auf die Geschichte zurückblickt
kann man vielleicht weil es lange her
ist all diese Kräfte sehen aber heute
sehen wir diese Kräfte in den
Nachrichten irgendwie nie was wir sehen
sind Politiker die Reden halten aber wir
wissen nicht wirklich wessen Interessen
sie dienen wer hinter den Kulissen
steckt
nun deshalb brauchen wir Forschung wir
müssen verstehen wer Amerika regiert der
Mythos heute ist dass die Menschen
Amerika regieren und die meisten Leute
wissen nicht viel über die Rolle die die
Unternehmen spielen die Art und Weise
wie Politiker mit den Interessen der
Unternehmen verbunden sind
Veränderung ist möglich ich glaube wenn
man darüber spricht wer Amerika regiert
sollte man das nicht dazu benutzen
einfach in Resignation zu verfallen und
zu sagen naja Veränderung ist eh nicht
möglich alles wird kontrolliert viele
der großen Volksbewegungen in unserer
Geschichte waren große Überraschungen
niemand hat sie kommen sehen und ich
glaube dasselbe gilt für Occupy Wall
Street niemand hat erwartet dass die
Bewegung einfach aus dem Nichts
auftauchen würde das haben wir in
unserer Geschichte immer wieder gesehen
und das werden wir auch weiterhin
die Leute sagen dass eine Prozent wir
sind die 99%. aber als ich die Zahlen
aufgeschlüsselt habe war es wirklich es
sind ein paar hundert Leute in diesem
Land die einen immensen Reichtum haben
wenn man sich unseren Wahlprozess
anschaut ist es ungefähr 100 Stück von
einem Prozent das für etwa 80% der
Wahlkampffinanzierung verantwortlich ist
das ist Wahnsinn das ist ein
manipuliertes Spiel
und jetzt ist der Ball der Geschichte an
eine neue Generation weitergereicht
worden die darum kämpft ein großes und
komplexes Land mit vielen Machtzentren
umzugestalten aber genau wie in der
Vergangenheit sind es entschlossene
Minderheiten die den Unterschied machen
eine Elite hat die amerikanische
Revolution angestoßen
als der pensionierte general dright
David Eisenhauer aus dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg für das Präsidentenamt
kandidierte wurde er als militärischer
Retter und amerikanischer Held aus
Kansas gefeiert
[Musik]
jetzt ist es an der Zeit dass alle guten
Amerikaner ihrem Land zu Hilfe kommen
wählen Sie Eisenhower niemand hat
erwartet dass er in seiner Abschiedsrede
das Entstehen einer neuen
Machtkonstellation des militärisch
industriellen komplexes vorhersagen und
bekämpfen würde
in den Regierungsräten müssen wir uns
vor der Erlangung eines
ungerechtfertigten Einflusses hüten ob
sie nun vor militärisch industriellen
Komplex angestrebt werden oder nicht das
Potenzial für den verhängnisvollen
Aufstieg fehlgeleiteter macht ist
vorhanden und wird Fortbestehen wir
dürfen nicht zulassen dass das Gewicht
dieser Kombination unsere Freiheiten
oder demokratischen Prozesse gefährdet
eine prophetische Rede vor allem für
einen militärischen Führer der erkannte
dass eine Verschmelzung von regierungs-
und Unternehmens macht zudem führen
könnte was er als ungerechtfertigten
Einfluss und fehlgeleitete macht
bezeichnete
50 Jahre später dokumentierte Präsident
Eisenhowers Enkelin Susen wie der
militärisch industrielle Komplex
gewachsen ist
sie schrieb das unsere Militär und
sicherheitsausgaben in weniger als 10
Jahren um 119 Prozent gestiegen sind
dieses Buch über den militärisch
industriellen Komplex von William
Hartung beschreibt detailliert die Macht
die er ausübt er erzählte mir wie er
funktioniert
das Pentagon die im Grunde ihre
Interessen auf Kosten der Steuerzahler
der nationalen Sicherheit und in einigen
Fällen der Zivilbevölkerung durchsetzen
ist das eine Beschreibung einer
tatsächlichen Realität
nun der militärische industrielle
komplex ist heute wahrscheinlich realer
als zu der Zeit als Eisenhower den
Begriff prägte eine Firma wie Lockheed
Marken baut nicht nur Raketen sie baut
Streubomben sie baut U-Boote
gleichzeitig helfen sie bei der
Bearbeitung Ihrer Steuern machen die
Volkszählung betreiben Fingerabdruck
Datenbanken für das FBI es ist also mehr
als nur der militärische industrielle
Komplex es ist eine Art nationaler
Sicherheitsstaat sowohl Überwachung als
auch Waffenbau
Hartung sagt diese Unternehmen diktieren
unsere Außenpolitik
sie haben unsere Außenpolitik und unsere
Militärpolitik zu einem großen Teil für
spezielle interessenvereinamt der
Schriftsteller Davids Ronson glaubt dass
dieser militärisch industrielle Komplex
auf Kriege oder die Gefahr von Kriegen
angewiesen ist um im Geschäft zu bleiben
Präsident Eisenhower hat in derselben
Rede und während seiner gesamten
laufbahnkriegs-propaganda betrieben aber
er hätte nicht mehr recht haben können
er konnte sich wahrscheinlich nicht
vorstellen wie groß das Problem des
militärisch industriellen komplexes
werden würde ich beschreibe es als eine
jährliche Rettungsaktion für die Banken
es geht um über eine Million Dollar
jedes Jahr für die Maschinerie des
Massenmords das ist mehr als die Hälfte
der diskretionären Bundesausgaben der
US-Regierung es ist mehr als alle
anderen Nation der Welt jedes Jahr das
Militär stecken ein Großteil davon ist
nicht rechenschaftspflichtig das
Pentagon verliert routinemäßig
Geldmengen die so groß sind wie das was
die meisten anderen
regierungsabteilungen bekommen
es geht nicht nur darum dass mehr Geld
für Waffen ausgegeben wird der Aufstieg
des militärisch industriellen komplexes
wurde von einem allgemeinen macht
Zuwachs der Unternehmen begleitet nicht
nur im militärischen Bereich
militärische Auftragnehmer haben jetzt
einen unverhältnismäßig großen Einfluss
sagt Sheila Krummholz vom Center for
responsive
politicsumme die vor allem von
Rüstungsunternehmen kommt diese reichen
von AT&T bis Boeing den größten
multi-nationalen goliats ihre
Haupteinnahmequelle mag die
Telekommunikation oder das
Transportwesen sein aber sie haben
riesige Verträge im Wert von einer Tonne
Geld mit dem Verteidigungsministerium
und dem Militär
es gab eine Reihe von Gesetzen die
darauf abzielen diese Verbindung
transparenter zu machen
und zu versuchen die Art von pay to play
Methode zu unterbinden
die zum Beispiel ihr Max bestimmen
gibt es ein Muster das Militär und
Industrieunternehmen die mit dem
Pentagon Geschäfte machen immer mehr
Geld an Politiker Zahlen
many tractors viele Rüstungsunternehmen
haben Beiträge geleistet viel Geld für
die Lobbyarbeit ausgegeben und im
Gegenzug Aufträge erhalten für die Sie
vielleicht nicht die besten
Voraussetzungen mitbrachten es wurde
also viel darüber geforscht wie Geld die
Kurven der Rüstungsunternehmen schmiert
ich würde auch sagen dass die Drehtür
eine wichtige Rolle spielt es geht also
nicht nur um Geld es sind andere Formen
des Einflusses der Elite wo Leute im
Verteidigungsministerium ihren Sprung in
die Privatwirtschaft antreten wo sie in
lukrativen Posten die Sie zu Regulierung
nutzen riesige Geldsummen einstreichen
können
neben dem Militär gibt es riesige
Nachrichtendienste mit enormen Budgets
und zu spionieren verdeckte Aktionen
durchzuführen persönliche Daten zu
sammeln und zu verschleiern wie mächtige
Interessen agieren heute leidet der
ehemalige CIA-Chef das Pentagon und
wurde durch einen General ersetzt der
Chef der Navy Seals leitet das
Zentralkommando Geheimhaltung ist in
einem nationalen Sicherheitsstaat
allgegenwärtig selbst wenn Gruppen wie
Wikileaks versuchen versteckte
Informationen zu verbreiten
Ihr Baby hat in den letzten Jahren mehr
geheime Dokumente veröffentlicht als
alle anderen Medien der Welt zusammen
kann das überhaupt wahr sein
ja kann das überhaupt wahr sein es ist
eine Sorge nicht wahr dass der Rest der
Weltmedien einen so schlechten Job macht
dass eine kleine Gruppe von Aktivisten
in der Lage ist mehr solcher
Informationen zu veröffentlichen als die
restliche Weltpresse zusammen
Jahre zuvor sagte der automobil-manager
und heutige Verteidigungsminister
Charles Wilson was gut für General
Motors sei sei gut für Amerika er sah
keinen Unterschied zwischen einer
gewählten Regierung und einem nicht
gewählten Unternehmen die m war ein
Autokonzern der durch Militärausgaben zu
einem wichtigen rüstungslieferanten
wurde und Jahre später zu einem
Hypotheken Finanzierer der durch von der
Wall Street initiierte und oft
betrügerische subprime Kredite
angetrieben wurde bisher fast zusammen
brach und vom Staat gerettet werden
musste
der Oberste Gerichtshof der Vereinigten
Staaten hat in seinem citizens United
Urteil entschieden das Unternehmen wie
GM die rechte gewöhnlicher Menschen
haben und offen und manchmal heimlich
Lobbyarbeit im Kongress und in der
Öffentlichkeit betreiben oder politische
Kampagnen finanzieren können um ihre
Ziele zu fördern es gibt nun viele
Kritikpunkte gegen citizen United viele
der Argumente sind in diesem Video der
Kampagne Story zu sehen
unsere Demokratie ist in der Krise 85%
der Amerikaner finden dass die
Unternehmen zu viel Macht haben und die
Menschen zu wenig 85 Prozent hey das ist
eine Mehrheit also lasst uns unsere
Demokratie von den Konzernen
zurückerobern das ist der wichtigste
Schritt auf dem Weg zu echten
Fortschritten bei allen Themen die den
Menschen am Herzen liegen
es gibt auch eine gegen Kampagne gegen
die Kontrolle der Politik durch
Unternehmen die sich auf zwei
Milliardäre als politische Geldgeber
konzentriert Charles und Edward Cook
zwei Brüder beide industrielle und
Geldgeber konservativer Kampagnen
einschließlich einer zu Unterdrückung
der Wahlbeteiligung der Demokraten Filme
Macher robert greenwold hat dieses Video
landesweit verbreitet
Leute wie die Gebrüder Krug versuchen
dafür zu sorgen dass möglichst wenige
people of color und junge Menschen zur
Wahl gehen
wir haben einen Staatsstreich hinter uns
wir leben in einem kooperativen Staat
Chris Hedges ist Bestsellerautor und
ehemaliger Reporter der New York Times
die Leute die Amerika regieren sind die
großen übernationalen Konzerne sie haben
keine Loyalität gegenüber dem
Nationalstaat sie plündern das Land
genauso aus wie sie den Rest der Welt
ausplündern sie führen einen globalen
neoforderismus ein bei dem die Arbeiter
auf der ganzen Welt wettbewerbsfähig
sein müssen sie müssen mit
sweatshop-arbeitern in Bangladesch die
22 Cent pro Stunde verdienen oder mit
Gefängnisarbeit in China konkurrieren es
ist ein globaler neoforderismus es ist
einer der unangreifbar ist völlig
unantastbar und mächtiger als die
Regierung in der Gastländer die dort
nominell ansässig waren
mit dieser Ansicht nicht allein
professor Michael claire hat sich auf
die Untersuchung der größten Industrie
des Landes spezialisiert Öl und Gas
die Ölindustrie oder Energie im
allgemeinen Kohle Erdgas uran ist die
mächtigste Lobby in Amerika das
mächtigste wirtschaftliche Interesse und
sie ist mit anderen mächtigen Interessen
verbunden mit der Automobilindustrie dem
Autobahnbau den Vorstädten vielen
anderen Industrie dem Tourismus die alle
mit der Energie verbunden sind und sie
arbeiten zusammen um Amerika vom Öl
abhängig zu machen und den Übergang zu
alternativen Brennstoffen zu verhindern
haben sie einen Einfluss auf unsere
Politik darauf was in Washington
passiert an den Wahlurnen in Amerika
sie sind die größten Beitragszahler für
Wahlkampagnen im allgemeinen
insbesondere für die republikanische
Partei und ich glaube sie haben einen
sehr starken Einfluss glauben Sie die
Amerikaner wissen wie mächtig sie sind
nur die Leute die diese Macht in ihrem
täglichen Leben sehen haben die Stärke
dieser Macht Begriffen für
Amerikaner ist der
militärischindustrielle Komplex nur eine
Quelle von Arbeitsplätzen und in der Tat
gewinnen militärische Auftragnehmer
politische Unterstützung und
Bundesmittel indem sie versprechen
Arbeitsplätze zu schaffen
es gibt tatsächlich Arbeitsplätze in den
Waffenfabriken und all den
Zulieferbetrieben aber es ist ein Betrug
denn man könnte die gleichen Gelder in
jeder andere Branche stecken in die
Infrastruktur in grüne Energie die
Bildung oder sogar in Steuersenkungen
für die arbeitende Bevölkerung und man
würde mehr Arbeitsplätze schaffen als
mit den Militärausgaben es ist also
schlimmer als nichts rein wirtschaftlich
gesehen seit Jahren gibt es Proteste
gegen Amerikas Kriege und das Militär
aber die meisten richteten sich gegen
Politiker nicht unbedingt gegen die
Unternehmen die von der
Waffenherstellung und anderen Produkten
für das Militär profitieren
[Musik]
eine der sichtbarsten Gruppen die sich
gegen den Militarismus wenden ist eine
Frauengruppe Code pink Media benjamin
ist einer der mitbegründerinnen
ich habe gelernt dass wir Amerika nicht
regieren
dass die Demokraten Amerika nicht
regieren die Konzerne regieren Amerika
ich habe mich mit den Kriegen
beschäftigt und das hat mich einfach
umgehauen wie mächtig diese
Waffenhersteller sind und die
Auftragnehmer und dass sie die Fähigkeit
haben Kriege am Laufen zu halten ich
meine das ist ziemlich erstaunlich wenn
man darüber nachdenkt ich beschäftige
mich gerade sehr viel mit dem Thema
Drohnen wussten Sie dass es im Kongress
einen drohnenausschuss gibt ich meine
statt einen Ausschuss für die Ernährung
von Vorschulkindern zu gründen haben sie
beschlossen dass es wichtiger ist einen
drohnenausschuss zu haben und das nur
weil alle Hersteller in ihren Bezirken
sie finanzieren
können ist offen damit um tatsächlich
haben über 50 Mitglieder des Kongresses
einen Ausschuss für Drohnen gegründet
indem sie offen für den Einsatz und den
Verkauf und Drohnen im Innen und Ausland
werben und sie haben jetzt mindestens
30.000 Drohnen im amerikanischen
Luftraum für jeden Zweck genehmigt im
Gegensatz dazu gibt es keinen Ausschuss
für Senioren für Kinder für die
Gesundheitsversorgung für grüne Energie
für Menschen es gibt einen Ausschuss für
Roboter
Eisenhauer hatte so recht als er sagte
das ist Geld stiehlt das ist uns die
Nahrung für unsere Kinderraum und für
die Gesundheitsversorgung unserer Eltern
und es wird einfach immer schlimmer das
sind diese kleinen Marionetten im
Kongress und ich lebe jetzt den
Washington also sehe ich diese kleinen
Marionetten und ich wünschte sie würden
den Firmennamen auf ihren Anzügen tragen
aber sie regieren Amerika nicht
natürlich regieren die Konzerne Amerika
und wenn es um Krieg und Frieden geht
sind diese Konzerne so mächtig dass sie
uns das letzte Jahrzehnt im Krieg
gehalten haben und wenn wir nichts
dagegen tun werden Sie uns auch im
nächsten Jahrzehnte im Krieg halten
jenseits der Debatten über die Rolle des
Militärs gibt es möglicherweise eine
tiefere Herausforderung denn die USA
haben sich von einer Nation zu einem
Imperium entwickelt mit einem weit
verzweigten System von Stützpunkten
wirtschaftlichen Interessen und
verflochtenen Geschäftsbeziehungen in
der ganzen Welt bei Elite Treffen wieder
bilderbergkonferenz der Trilateralen
Kommission und dem Internationalen
Währungsfond kommen führende Politiker
mit unternehmensbossen zusammen das
alles ist Teil einer globalen Struktur
von Unternehmenskultur
ik und macht
einige wie der Milliardär George Soros
sagten mir das Weltwirtschaftsforum sei
er einen networking-party als ein Ort
der Entscheidungsfindung
werden oft hinter den Kulissen getroffen
nicht auf öffentlichen Veranstaltungen
Davos das Treffen in Davos ist eine
riesige Cocktailparty Cocktail es werden
viele Kontakte geknüpft Menschen treffen
sich und so weiter es werden viele Dinge
besprochen es ist eigentlich sehr
praktisch weil man in einem begrenzten
Zeitraum eine Menge Leute treffen kann
wie man treffen möchte und es ist auch
ein Mädchen Ereignis
ist es auch ein Symbol für das Wachstum
von wirtschaftlicher Macht von
übermäßiger politischer Macht für den
Verlust der Souveränität eine Kalender
[Musik]
nun es ist tatsächlich symptomatisch für
das Zeitalter in dem Präsidenten und
Premierminister die Finanziers und
industriellen umwerben
nur wenige Amerikaner scheinen zu
verstehen wie kooperativierung und
Globalisierung Hand in Hand gehen
war einer der ersten Aktivisten gegen
den Vietnamkrieg er glaubt dass der
Amerikaner die Fakten nicht sehen können
weil sie in Mythen gefangen sind ich
habe ihn gefragt wie er die Menschen auf
dem Mars diese Situation erklären würde
müsste Ihnen einige sehr verrückte Dinge
erklären ich müsste es mit Begriffen
erklären die Sie vielleicht verstehen
ich dürfte einige der Begriffe die
Amerikaner üblicherweise verwenden nicht
benutzen denn wenn man die Sprache
verwendet die uns in der Schule
beigebracht wird über Demokratie freien
Willen dass die USA die Nummer eins sind
all diese Begriffe führen dazu dass man
nicht verstehen kann was sie sagen
nämlich dass es wirklich und zwar schon
seit langem einen sehr kleinen
Prozentsatz gibt einen Prozent oder so
der wirklich die meisten Entscheidungen
trifft aber sie sind klug genug sie auf
eine Weise zu treffen die die meisten
Amerikaner bis vor kurzem davon abhielt
zu erkennen dass sie beherrscht werden
und wir können die Plutokratie die
Kleptokratie nicht rückgängig machen
ohne den militärischen industriellen
Komplex abzubauen das sind hier ein
Prozent der ein Prozent wir hätten
Banken ohne auch nur einen Cent davon
zurückzubekommen wir leines uns von
China Zahlen es mit Zinsen zurückhalten
die Zinssätze lächerlich niedrig wenn
die Wall Street zum Einsturz helfen ihr
aus der Patsche weil wir eine
Kriegswirtschaft geschaffen haben ohne
dass ein Krieg nötig wäre
wenn die Menschen einen besseres Gespür
dafür hätten wie diese Unternehmen das
Militär ihre Verbündeten im Kongress die
Show leiten und uns in Angst und
Schrecken versetzen damit wir Geld für
Waffen ausgeben die wir nicht brauchen
dann denke ich hätten sie die Anfänger
eines Instruments um etwas dagegen zu
tun aber ohne diese Informationen gibt
es keinen Ansatzpunkt um sich dagegen zu
wehren
also müsste ich den Marsianer sagen das
ist sehr schwer für sie sein wird zu
verstehen warum die Amerikaner nicht
sehen wie sie verarscht werden Sie sehen
es nicht
sei denn es wird so schlimm oder so
widersprüchlich oder so persönlich dass
sie eines Tages aufwachen und sagen oh
mein Gott
heißt das dass die Wirtschaft die Wall
Street die Rüstungskonzerne eine
unverhältnismäßige Macht haben
mit anderen Worten sind sie die Kräfte
die unser Land regieren krank von denen
die meisten Menschen nicht einmal etwas
wissen
ich glaube dass das Geld in allen
Bereichen großen Einfluss hat besonders
dort wo die Themen undurchsichtig sind
und den durchschnittlichen Amerikanern
fremd zu sein scheinen wo die Wähler
nicht aufpassen und von ihren Vertretern
in Washington nicht gehört werden
dort wo die Menschen aufhorchen wo es
einen Aufschrei der normalen Menschen
gibt ist es für das Geld schweren die
Verdienste in der Politik zu übertreffen
von ihnen nachsagt sie würden den
Interessen Nachkommen die ihre Kampagne
finanzieren
so unklug sind sie normalerweise nicht
der Großteil der Öffentlichkeit hat
keine Berührungspunkte mit dem
militärischindustriellen Komplex weil
sie als Verbraucher an der Wirtschaft
teilhaben aber selbst dort sind sie von
einer Machtverschiebung betroffen in
einer wirtschaftlichen Ungleichheit die
sie immer tiefer in die Schulden treibt
georgestellter eines Unternehmens das
andere Unternehmen berät heute braucht
man 200.000 Dollar im Jahr um sich
einigermaßen Wohlhaben zu fühlen ich
habe dort gefragt wie sich seiner
Meinung nach die wachsende Ungleichheit
auf unsere Politik auswirkt wer hat das
Sagen in unserem Land wir lesen immer
mehr über das große Geld in der Politik
es gab einen großartigen Artikel über
die ein Prozent von den Prozent für die
ein Prozent weil vielleicht war es
Vanity Fair ich bin mir nicht mehr
sicher aber sie haben auf einen Punkt
hingewiesen den ich in der Politik und
in der Wirtschaft immer wieder anspreche
nämlich das seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
die Anzahl der Personen den Unterschied
ausmacht eine Person eine Stimme also
spielt man mit der Stimme eine Person
ein Dollar man hat so viele Menschen wie
möglich angesprochen und die Dollar zu
bekommen da sich jetzt aber das Vermögen
am oberen Ende in den Händen einiger
weniger konzentriert ist Geld sowohl für
Politiker als auch für Vermarkter viel
wertvoller als die Masse der Menschen
die die Mittelschicht ausmachen
wird jetzt also die Masse der Menschen
aus dem vorgelassen
sie werden vielleicht nicht
vernachlässigt aber sie sind sicherlich
weniger wichtig ich glaube dass sie in
vielerlei Hinsicht in der Politik
weniger beachtet und in gewisser Weise
mehr manipuliert werden und was das
Marketing angeht wird es weniger
Produkte und weniger Dienst Wohnungen
geben das ist eine Sichtweise aus der
Unternehmenswelt die im Wesentlichen
besagt dass die Mehrheit der Amerikaner
weniger wirtschaftliche Macht und
folglich auch weniger politische Macht
hat
Leute mit Geld regieren Amerika und
diese Leute mit Geld können dadurch
Macht erlangen aber das großartige an
Amerika ist dass wir alle in dem Mythos
leben dass jeder von uns etwas bewirken
kann und ich denke es gibt genug
Möglichkeiten die mich glauben lassen
dass die Zukunft nicht so düster ist wie
es manchmal scheint
das wollen wir hoffen sicherlich glauben
die meisten Amerikaner dass ihre Zukunft
rosig ist aber bei den Trends die wir in
Bezug auf die Machthaber untersucht
haben gibt es sicherlich Zweifel vor
allem wegen der Gefahr und Bedrohung
durch neue Kriege die laut Professor
stanowitz im Geheimen geplant werden
es wird einen Krieg gegen den Iran geben
in der Tat wenn man Embargos nicht
mitzählt ist das was in diesem Moment
also im März 2012 passiert praktisch
eine Kriegshandlung wir sagen den
Iranern entweder ihr beugt euch unsere
Forderung keine Atomwaffen zu entwickeln
und auf Atomwaffen zu verzichten oder
wir sperren eure waren weiterhin aus
schließlich ist der Markt Teil des
Systems sie sagen also ihr habt keine
Marktrechte
es ist also gerade ein Krieg im Gange
ich denke schon aber die meisten
Amerikaner wissen es nicht wirklich oder
richtig wissen Sie wirklich von dieser
Macht Elite nein wissen Sie wovon sie
write Milz vor so vielen Jahren
gesprochen hat warum und wie kann sich
das ändern
weil wir keine linke haben die wirklich
kontinuierlich und effektiv darüber
spricht wer in Amerika die Macht hat
sprach davon dass 99% der Menschen
wirtschaftlich entmachtet sind und von
Ungleichheit aber das ist nicht einmal
annähernd eine Analyse die in der
gesamten Gesellschaft verbreitet werden
kann wir haben kein System von
Tageszeitungen wir haben keine
Wochenzeitung wir haben Twitter wir
haben verschiedene andere Arten von
sozialen Medien zu denen wir Zugang
haben aber das ersetzt nicht die Art von
systematischer Analyse die durch unsere
eigenen Medien stattfinden könnte
Amerikaner tappen also in gewisser Weise
noch im Dunkeln ich glaube das linke
Forum und viele andere Bemühungen sind
versuche das zu ändern ja das stimmt
selbst als Präsident Eisenhauer den
militärischindustriellen Komplex
entlaste brachte er auch den tief
empfundenen Wunsch der Amerikaner nach
Frieden und Gerechtigkeit zum Ausdruck
stehen die Geschichte weitgehend
vergessen hat
und das im Laufe der Zeit alle Völker in
Frieden Zusammenleben werden garantiert
durch die bindende Kraft der
gegenseitigen Achtung und Liebe
[Musik]